evernote's privacy policy so i'm a big
fan of evernote i use it every day
really every single day of my life i use
evernote for my business for my personal
for my travel for my receipts everything
is in evernote and i got asked a
question from one of my youtube viewers
love you guys
kenure who wrote how about privacy i
found loading every document to evernote
quite a problem this is a really
important question and one that actually
got me a little bit upset not with kenor
but with with evernote i'll tell you why
so privacy is a huge thing right you're
uploading all your stuff there's a lot
of personal stuff that's getting
uploaded to evernote servers privacy is
going to be
an important thing that everybody's
going to care about it's one of the most
most asked questions that i get about
evernote is around privacy
and
for me
you know i went to their website they
have links on privacy and and they talk
a big game right great fine what
convinced me was that i have friends who
are
anal about privacy who really care about
it who are lawyers who take this very
seriously and they ran through
everything with a fine-tooth comb and
they use evernote for their stuff so if
it's good enough for them then it's good
enough for me from a privacy point of
view but here's why i'm upset this is
why i'm upset okay because
i reached out to evernote and i said hey
i have a reader an entrepreneur who's
asking about privacy can you
can you share some resources
and can we maybe talk about it and do an
interview to talk about evernote in
their privacy and how you really take
this seriously and they wrote back and
they sent me four links about their
privacy policy and cookie usage and all
of the security related stuff related to
evernote and it's it's boring technical
crap for me right for others maybe you
love reading through that stuff for me
it's boring and you know what i'm gonna
share those four links in the
description of the video for those of
you who are interested in it but i said
you know what
this is about creating trust with people
right you want people to trust you
they're giving you their most important
information so they better trust you
what we need to do what i recommend is
let's have a an interview let's do a
hangout on on my youtube channel where i
can ask you questions and people can see
a face so not just reading boring
corporate legal documents right give me
a face because if i can see somebody and
relate to them and i can feel their
passion for privacy and data protection
then i'm going to be more likely to
trust you right this is about building
trust
what better way to build trust and to
have somebody passionately speak about
privacy so i suggested that to them and
no response no response dude
i'm dropping evernote videos all the
time educating my audience educating you
guys because i believe it's a great
service for entrepreneurs and they can't
even respond to a tweet and so
i love the service you know i love the
company i'm still a fan i'm still using
it every day in my life but
dude the the pr team needs a major shake
in the head because you guys really suck
and and phil libben you know who's the
the ceo of evernote i hope you look into
it man because your team is letting you
down anyway great product great service
i'll include the uh
the links to the four links that they
sent me because that's all they sent me
but it has some information on their
privacy policy
and um i hope that the rest of the day
goes better i believe for those of you
watching you like this video
subscribe to the channel
maybe show me some love in the comments
too i love to hear from you let me know
what you're up to let me know if you
have ever no questions
that's it i'll see you soon